j'accueille maintenant alex métayer
bonsoir alex métayer
on a parlé beaucoup politique ce soir
métier trotskiste vous mais si je dis
trotskiste les téléspectateurs vont
penser à une maladie de la peau
ah bon parce que vous croyez qu'il soit
plus que se tient ce coup je ferai ce
que vous savez que le
j'espère a été accusée dit on oui à
moins que ces emprunts ont dit que c'est
le gym a lancé par le scoop c'est que il
faisait partie de ma cellule ah c'est
vrai ça non regardez là des ouvriers
non mais c'est vrai que c'est pas vrai
et je revois ce blood in est énorme ça
je me souviens que sur les barricades en
mai 68 il avait seulement un problème
c'est que quand on lui disait va là bas
à gauche il aller à droite
donc j'ai connu un jospin j'ai connu
réellement un jeu c'était lui ou son
fera lors voilà j'en suis au même point
que vous ah oui d'accord
vous êtes connu un jospin trotskisme on
sait pas si c'est lionel jamais on va
parler de vous alex métayer on va parler
de votre qui s'appelle elle expédié par
la tête au palais royal jusqu'au 31
décembre 2000 c'est très drôle c'est un
cours de médecine humoristique c'est ça
c'est le travail des hormones
sur le désir de la jalousie la colère
j'ai voulu faire un cours magistral
déconnant illustré par des sketches
c'est à dire je suis un professeur qui
s'adresse au public et je suis parti de
données scientifiques exactes sur les
hormones le travail de nos organes dans
l'amour dans la haine dans la dans la
jalousie
je fais donc un court qui surprend au
début et une fois que les gens sont
rentrés dedans alors c'est formidable
parce que tout d'un coup il ya une
espèce de connivence scientifique avec
le bionic et on s'aperçoit que le public
est beaucoup plus intelligent qu'on
imagine toujours c'est à dire qu'il y à
une sorte de connaissances qu'on doit
peut-être d'ailleurs à télévision je
suis pas masquer cette grande maison de
la culture sur laquelle on tape il y à
il ya quand même un fond pendant que
louis ii qu'une pure quand même et voilà
donc ce spectacle-là qui s'appelle a
expédié par la tête est basée sur des
données s'intitule comportement hormonal
de l'homme en fait toutes nos passions
sont fait dû uniquement à des phénomènes
hormonaux ce qu'on imagine venir de
notre âme
en fait ça vient de la mécanique voilà
élan j'ai appris des choses très
intéressantes par exemple que quand
l'homme fait l'amour
il dégage une odeur suave ça faire
sourire je suis sûr que les femmes en
sont illégales qui s'apparente à
l'honneur du bois de santal avant
prouver c'est donc des données
scientifiques qui sont à la fois drôle
et à la fois juste et je crois que le
public rit à cause de cette connivence
entre la réalité et puis bon délire le
problème c'est que ça nous ramène un peu
vers des verts des grands primates quoi
ça nous ramène un peu vers des grands
singes
savez vous que que quand on est en
colère qu'un mec qui tend bagnole qui en
colère il a exactement les mêmes
hormones qu'un chimpanzé qui veut
devenir le maître dans le groupe 1
c'est à dire que on se trouve avec toute
une série d'hormones dans les dents dans
nos actions qui sont exactement celles
du monde animal ouais alors ministre de
la science fiction film en est un peu en
retard sur la vraie science parce que
l'explosion de la science est beaucoup
plus étonnantes finalement aujourd'hui
que tout ce que peut nous raconter la
science fiction
oui et surtout il y à une donnée de la
science fiction que j'aime pas du tout
qui est la donnée est pessimiste
c'est à dire toute la séance mission est
basée sur des deux
des projections qui sont pessimistes ne
sont plus au noir alors que ce qui se
passe avec la science j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit ça exactement
c'est un optimiste donc agi à la limite
intérim autrement je serais pas trop de
ce qui selon vous êtes toujours
trotskiste et s'est dit au prix du
muguet n'a pas bougé je sais pas je
savais que vous aviez été trotskiste
dans votre jeunesse vous êtes toujours
trop de ce clip non
ce serait ça serait une malhonnêteté de
ma part de dire et vous le savez que
pour être un militant il faut avoir
beaucoup de temps il faut passer du
temps mais si vous voulez parler de mes
convictions qui sont celles qui est un
changement nécessaire et inévitable
oui cela gêne alors vous devez trouver
que le parti communiste de robert hue et
pas du tout bien parce qu'ils sont
drôlement libéraux maintenant c'est le
copain de fac welch et de oui nous
sommes pas tout à fait sur la même
longueur d'onde autrement je serais au
pc évidemment mais c'est vrai que il
arrive qu'on se retrouve
il arrive qu'on se retrouve par quelques
aléas bizarre parfois sur la même
longueur d'onde mais non pensez quoi du
virage du pc depuis robert majur accès
une tentative désespérée d'exister je
crois que c'est une tentative d'exister
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit lié à
parti révolutionnaire bien parti à
partir du moment où vous êtes dans le
gouvernement et que vous cautionnez
l'édition la différence par exemple
entre ce que disent les socialistes
aujourd'hui nous sommes au gouvernement
avec eux quand ils disaient qu'ils
refusaient la société de marché mais
qu'ils acceptent socialistes disent ça
le premier ministre l'a dit ben ça veut
dire qui veut réguler le marché
capitaliste le système capitaliste et
bien moi comme communiste
j'ai pas envie de me contenter de le
réguler
j'ai envie de le dépasser donc on est
tous à dans les petites séances bien
subtile viens on va regarder en tous les
cas ce que vous faites au théâtre du
palais royal